leaders are so often so concerned about
their status of their position and
organization they actually forget their
real job and the real job of a leader is
not about being in charge it's about
taking care of those in our charge and I
don't think people realize this and I
don't think people train for this when
we're junior our only responsibility is
to be good at our jobs that's all we
really have to do and some people
actually go get advanced education and
so that they can be really good at their
jobs accountants or whatever right and
you show up and you work hard and the
company will give us tons and tons of
training how to do our jobs they'll show
us how to use the software they'll send
us away for a few days to get trained in
whatever it is that we're doing for the
company and then they expect us to go be
good at our jobs and that's what we do
we work very hard and if you're good at
your job they'll promote you and at some
point you'll get promoted to position
where we're now responsible for the
people who do the job we used to do but
nobody shows us how to do that and
that's why we get managers and not
leaders because the reason our managers
are micromanaging us is because they
actually do know how to do the job
better than us that's what got them
promoted really what we have to do is go
through a transition some people make it
quickly some people make it slowly and
unfortunately some people will never
make that transition at all which is we
have to go this through this transition
of being responsible for the job and
then turning it to somebody who's now
responsible for the people who are
responsible for the job
[Music]
[Music]